you know I never really consider myself
a car guy I used to used to have an old
sports car but I got rid of it again I
used to just consider a driving a car to
be a thing you did to get from A to B
electric cars had changed my view about
that they're a better way to drive cars
I love technology I've been involved
with it for ages I was one of the people
lucky enough to help build the Internet
in Australia inside I got this very
early book of technology and it's really
been a huge part of my life ever since
almost everything I do is about using
technology to make something happen
that's better the car has so many things
that you would expect from a car built
in the era of the internet car built in
the era of modern computers what I guess
I hadn't expected was that I was getting
into something it was like a spaceship
it was like sitting in the future one of
the big things about it is the
application that's on the tanja
smartphone that you talk to the vehicle
so you can remotely turn on the
air-conditioning or remotely figure out
where the car is if you forgot where
you've left it the things been designed
to be one smooth driving experience and
one smooth interaction
because the model s is such a software
driven environment it does actually
integrate with the work aspects of my
life really quite well as well so you
get into the car in the morning and your
daily appointments are sitting on the
screen ready for you if you want to go
driving somewhere the car already knows
where you're heading so it's very easy
to load that destination into the coat
the vehicle becomes an extension of you
tests are very good at producing a
virtuous cycle with their own owners
myself included in terms of getting
suggesting tram owners incorporating
them into future software updates so the
car is growing and changing in terms of
its capabilities as its owner's driver
it's a lovely thing to feel like the car
is wrapped around you and use think your
way around the road now if you buy a
conventional car your interaction with
the people that made it is ended at that
point if you buy one of these cars your
interaction is only just begun